for more on the crisis at our southern
border we are joined by texas republican
congressman and ranking member of the
house ways and means committee kevin
brady congressman welcome
thanks mike thanks for having me all
indications are the situation at the
border has not gotten better it's likely
gotten worse is it time for someone high
ranking in the biden administration to
resign
you know i would think it's beyond that
time uh look this is all predictable
we've said this for months the situation
the border is not getting better it's
not but but getting worse and when you
visit with the border patrol agents
they've been
crying this out for months and months
now we're seeing it happen no one
led by this president vice president
seems to care about the humanitarian
crisis here about the danger of these uh
illegal migrants entering the us uh and
so far they've managed to uh by ignoring
it apparently uh
avoid their responsibility but i don't
we've never seen it like this in texas i
don't think we've ever seen this frankly
in the united states it can continue
we're showing our viewers live images of
that
scene under the bridge in del rio texas
uh your reaction to seeing all those
people an estimated 13 000 people
camped out under that bridge
yeah it is uh it's stunning uh and it's
disheartening uh and it is again reminds
me i think of all the children we saw
crammed into those detention centers
earlier this year i was in del rio uh
and at the time even though it wasn't
getting a lot of attention you're
already seeing and hearing from the
mayor
just a number of vehicle chases the
property damage
the residents scared
about frankly their safety in a town
that hadn't been affected like this
before this was months ago it is only
worsened and again will not get any
better i it is unconscionable that the
president ignores this crisis and the
danger that that it presents reports are
haitian migrants are going to be flown
back to haiti uh but they obviously
didn't just walk across the border have
you given any thought to how the heck
haitians are getting to our southern
border and who's
basically running the show
yeah it is difficult to tell two
thoughts one uh they didn't come by they
aren't coming by accident clearly the
word is out
that if that there are open borders in
the us's and this is how you access it
what we read and hear about there seems
to be different password pathways that
the haitians are taking here to get to
this border no one a clear path there
but but no question about it they know
there's an open border here they're
willing to risk it and again this is all
these are dangerous journeys especially
for young women and young men and
and i don't understand how this
president can ignore it an hour longer
to pressing deadlines in congress
funding runs out at the end of the month
and the need to raise the debt ceiling
allowing the government to borrow more
money here's the house budget chairman
today
i don't know what the political
calculation one way or the other is i
personally would like to see a clean
vote on a debt ceiling so that
republicans actually have to go on the
record on that vote only and not not mix
it with
a
a
funding measure but ultimately
the most important thing is to get both
of them done
do you expect speaker pelosi to combine
a funding extension and debt into one
package
yeah i do i think they're risking their
they're raising the stakes uh in a way
that they could shut down this
government and i think do damage the
economy at the same time i don't
understand why why they are doing this
what chairman yarmouth
didn't talk about was that democrats
haven't had one conversation with one
republican about a plan not just to
raise the debt ceiling but to get our
financial house in order this emergency
spending far beyond the emergency will
[ __ ] our finances this country in the
future much less the three and a half
trillion dollars that they are proposing
and at this point you know it's the
democrats responsibility they're doing
the spending they're running everything
in a partisan way it's their job to get
this done to that three and a half
trillion dollar spending and tax package
what are your concerns about the taxes
included in that massive spending bill
yeah so i most americans think this
country is on the wrong track and this
is going to make it worse it will kill
american jobs drive prices up even
higher on families and i think hook a
whole new generation the poor on the
government dependency first this is an
economic surrender to uh china russia in
europe that will drive american jobs
overseas and could kill up to three
million american jobs over time
it is devastating tax hikes on main
street small businesses just as they're
trying to come out of the covet plus
they double the death tax the number of
family-owned businesses and farms
that'll be hit by the death tax and then
finally president biden clearly
breaks his pledge by raising taxes on
low-income and middle-class families
don't take my word for that both the
joint committee on taxation and the
left-leaning tax policy center say those
tax increases on the middle class could
start as early as next year fascinating
congressman kevin brady of the great
state of texas thanks so much for your
time sir good to see you mike thanks
thank you